this is a tragic and very sad day for  Germanwings and the entire Lufthansa  family I have to unfortunately inform  you that today over the French  Department I province in the South of  France  we had an accident with a plane of  Germanwings this plane was on its way on  a normal scheduled flight from Barcelona  to Duesseldorf  the plane at 6:48 in the morning left  düsseldorf and flew with a hundred and  twenty odd patients to Barcelona and  landed there on time at 8:57 the bus the  plane left Barcelona at 10:01 with the  destination Dusseldorf on board were 144  passengers among them two babies and in  total six crew members - in the cockpit  and four in the cabin as in flight staff  the plane as far as we now know it was  supposed to land at 11:35 and at 10:45  it left its regular flight height 38,000  feet they were reached at that time